6 12 is the time good morning scotland
is home to
138 whiskey distilleries which attracted
a record number of tourists right before
the pandemic almost 2.2 million wendy
gillette just returned from scotland
joining us live this morning from the
cbs broadcast center in new york with
more on how women are drinking whiskey
wendy i am on this trend i love whiskey
how fun for you to go over there
yeah heather it was a very tough
assignment but someone had to do it
visiting distilleries in scotland scotch
whiskey is big business shipping to 180
markets around the world it's made with
just three ingredients water yeast and
grain but by law it can only be made in
scotland
thank you kim mabus traveled from
philadelphia to the glen levitt
distillery in northeast scotland to buy
a few bottles she can only get here
pretty big scotch fan i have a nice
collection at home these days she's
enjoying it with a more diverse group so
many friends of mine have started
drinking whiskey with female friends
it's crazy
a 2020 study from the market research
company mri simmons shows more than a
third of whiskey drinkers are now women
at our bag distillery on the scottish
island of isla visitor center manager
jackie thompson estimates the percentage
of women guests drinking whiskey has
quadrupled since she entered the
business 25 years ago and she's observed
a difference in how women and men
approach scotch i see with women often
they have a great appreciation of
sticking their noses into whisky in
order to enjoy the flavor of whiskey and
men maybe tend to go straight for the
palate whereas women go for
the scent and the aroma of whiskey to
appreciate it women aren't just drinking
whiskey they're making it the scotch
whiskey association estimates 40 percent
of this country's 11 000 industry
employees are female and they're
breaking the glass ceiling in what used
to be a male dominated field kelsey
mckechnie was the youngest woman named
an apprentice malt master for balvenie
distillery at the age of 24. if you look
back in time women just weren't in these
roles and now they are she sees a future
with more women calling the shots in an
industry that just keeps getting bigger
the scotch whiskey association says
every second 44 bottles of scotland's
national drink are exported with four of
those bottles headed for the u.s
the distilled spirits council of the us
says the growth of super premium scotch
brands is driving sales here up 200
percent since 2003 heather wendy that is
really just incredible to see and what a
fun trip for you to take and kind of
learn so much i do have to ask because
you've been on some really great trips
recently kind of traveling around
you know travel's been a mess for a lot
of folks at least domestically what was
your experience heading over there
well like many travelers in europe this
summer there were issues with baggage
the delay arriving in edinburgh was
about an hour and 15 minutes to get bags
that's due to staffing shortages leaving
scotland baggage delays caused a delay
of a couple hours and that led to
missing a connection in washington but
at least we got our bags which is better
than other travelers have fared heather
wow no kidding and i guess overall you
get to go to a beautiful country meet
wonderful people and drink whiskey so
what's there to complain about
right
exactly wendy thank you so much for that
we appreciate your time this morning fun
to see how things have changed for that
business
take care
sure
we've got some more fun facts about
scotch whiskey as well which is really
kind of neat i know wendy kind of ran
through a lot of it their inner story
but in order for it to be considered
scotch it has to be made in scotland
it must be made from malted barley with
no fermentation additives it's got to be
aged at least three years in oak barrels
and one more thing it has to have
alcohol content
less than ninety four point eight
percent
i appreciate that i'm a whiskey drinker
so it's nice to see that business kind
of change over because yeah i think we
did always think it was a a gentleman's
drink sure so
on your horizons your palate yes i never
knew a malt master i didn't know that
was the name for them a malt master kind
of like